Welcome to Ear Biscuits.
I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at our individual tables of
either dining, or placed
into your living room,
Rhett, we are going to
have another discussion
because Ear Biscuits don't stop
because we're in our homes.
It's not that much different.
No it doesn't.
It's still working, it's still working.
You think this is work?
I don't even have pants on.
This is a nice outlet.
Today, you know what,
today's gonna be a positive outlet.
Just like you can sit
down and watch a movie,
and you can escape from the
reality of what's going on,
and there's, I mean,
there's some good news,
there's a lot of bad news, there's a lot,
there's still a lot of troubling news,
there's things to be worried about,
but you can escape into a book,
you can escape into a show,
you can escape into a movie,
and right now you can escape
into an Ear Biscuits about movies.
Yeah, we're going to do one of our
top 10 favorites episodes.
We're doing top 10 favorite movies
for each one of us personally,
going through our list.
We've had fun with this before.
What else did we do?
We did TV shows.
Was that the only?
We also did game shows, like specifically.
Yeah, well of course, yeah.
So--
This is a tough one because
this one's very broad.
Well, I'll say a few things about it,
it was incredibly
difficult to make this list
because as I've said
many times about my lists
of favorites is that I don't
have like a favorite movie,
I have like a collection of movies,
and once I started trying
to narrow down to 10
I started feeling really
bad about the ones
that I was leaving off at the top 10.
So I have a pretty long
list of honorable mentions.
I'm pretty sure you do as well.
I have some honorable mentions.
The thing that, it's not
that I had difficulty
narrowing it down, as much as I actually
had difficulty accessing some of those,
oh I remembered one that would
be like high up on my list,
and I'd be like I can't
believe I almost forgot
about this movie, it's been
so long since I've seen it.
But it's not just what we
think are the best movies ever,
but at least for me, I ranked the movies
that were most personally impactful,
the movies that were most meaningful to me
for a variety of reasons,
which I think is kind of what we do with
the television show thing as well.
Yeah, it's more about, I mean,
favorite doesn't necessarily mean--
Best.
Right.
Although, I would say the majority
of the movies that ended
up letting make the top 10
were the ones that, with few exceptions,
I still think these are just incredible,
there's not a film on this list
that's not an incredible film.
Right.
But it might not be that they're all 98%
or above on Rotten Tomatoes,
you know, that wasn't my criteria,
but also the way that I
kind of tried to access
the memories, which I
have a horrible memory,
unless I wrote something down,
is, I went to lists of movies.
Right.
You know, and so I'm,
there's probably, there might be something
that you accessed through your memory
that wouldn't have made like top 100.
Yeah.
I went like top 100 all genres
and like went through
all them to kind of like
re-access different movies.
Yeah.
But there could be one
that's not on there.
Anyway.
One of the things that I realized was
I've fallen out of the
habit of watching movies.
I don't, there's been different
eras of movie watching,
and I think it will
become clear on my list
as to when these movies
meant the most to me,
like when I first watched them,
and what what compels me
to go back and watch them.
But, you know, as television has evolved,
I find myself watching more
television than movies at home,
and not going to the theater,
or going to theater
for a different reason,
or going with different people
like with younger people,
that type of thing has
changed my movie going habits.
But in this current situation,
if there's ever been an opportunity
to go back and re-watch
movies or to introduce,
you know, your partner,
or your kids to movies
that were special to you,
now's a great time to do that.
Now we're just looking for
opportunities to do things,
and movies, they take
a good chunk of time.
So I guess you can just consider this
an entire recommendation
episode as we go through these.
Do you want to start?
Let's get into it.
Sure.
Of course we're starting with number 10
and work our way to number one.
And again, of course,
I don't know your list,
and you don't have my list, so.
Right.
My number 10 favorite movie of all time is
"The Good, The Bad and The Ugly."
Really?
I mean, I own that movie on DVD,
but I couldn't have even told
you that you've watched it.
What?
Are you crazy?
You didn't watch it with me.
I've watched every Clint
Eastwood movie multiple times.
Oh, not just like "A Fistful of Dollars,"
and "A Few Dollars More," but
all Clint Eastwood movies.
The Dollars trilogy, which is,
incidentally, this movie is considered
the third and final
installment in that trilogy,
even though it was basically
just marketed as that
because it was a spaghetti western,
it was an Italian produced
and directed movie.
And the reason I love
this, I wanted to have,
I wanted, first of all, I wanted
to have a Western in there
because--
Okay.
I love the genre.
Yeah.
But this is the most,
I'm actually surprised it is at least
not on your honorable
mentions because this is
the most iconic film score of all time.
That's true.
In my mind.
Yeah.
So, Ennio Morricone, he basically,
this is that classic, like so many,
so many things that you take for granted,
both in film scores
but also in filmmaking,
like, you know this soundtrack
even if you don't know that
you know this soundtrack.
I was trying to do it with my hands.
And it sounds a little bit like what Link
tried to do there, but it's like,
Yeah, there's like whip
sounds and stuff like that,
all that stuff that you just--
The soundtrack is great.
Like maybe top two or
three movie soundtracks
of all times, definitely.
But the movie itself, you got to settle in
because it's a different type of pacing.
The first 10 and a half
minutes there is no dialogue.
10 and a half minutes of no dialogue,
and the shots are incredible, like,
there's all these shots of just eyeballs.
And there's shots, incredibly wide,
the cinematography is absolutely amazing.
So, I did a little research
and learned that
Clint Eastwood was so frustrated
with making this movie
that he never worked
with the director again
because the director was
so meticulous about, like,
you see the final product
and the way that all the,
he worked the actor so hard
to get all of these different shots
that Clint Eastwood was like,
I'm never working with this guy again.
And people will kind of look down on
the whole spaghetti western thing.
A Sergio Leone.
I couldn't remember his
name, I looked it up.
Just a super weird time
in filmmaking history
in that all of a sudden they started
making a bunch of westerns in Italy.
And then like, they were some, you know,
like Spain was involved in
some ways, and I don't know,
I mean, and also the
whole thing is overdubbed.
So if you go back and watch this,
you're gonna be like, what?
They ADR-ed the entire movie
and it's super obvious,
but there's just something
about all the elements
that come together to just
make it iconic for me.
And the face, the three way face off scene
at the end is pretty, pretty memorable.
If you can last that long.
I think anybody, I mean I understand
that it's a certain taste but,
for me it's so iconic,
and it stands on its own
and it influenced so much of filmmaking.
Yeah.
From that point on that
it's just, I love it.
I did own it.
I actually might enjoy watching, like,
you know, "The Outlaw Josey Wales,"
or something like that more as a movie.
And then I love some of
the like, "Unforgiven"
and, later, like 90s.
So no other Western made your list?
No.
"Tombstone?"
No, "Tombstone's" not on the list.
I thought "Tombstone"
would be on your list.
Okay, my number 10
released in 2004.
This is a movie that I'd forgotten about
but it popped up as I
was doing some browsing
and I was like, I think
this needs to go on my list.
It barely made it, but
here it is at number 10,
"Napoleon Dynamite."
It's an honorable mention for me.
Okay.
It got a good got close to
making it on the list for sure.
"Napoleon Dynamite,"
Jared Hess movie, you know,
he made a short film, and then it,
I think that's what was it Slam Dance
which was like the companion
film festival to Sundance,
and, so, I'm pretty sure
I'm right about that,
that then they turn it
into a full length movie,
and it was based on his
experiences in grown up in Idaho
and like the llama that's in it is his
mom's or his grandma's llama
because she really had one.
And last night, didn't
have anything to do,
and I was like, Lily and Lando and I
were gonna watch something, I was like,
let's watch a movie,
I think you'll like "Napoleon Dynamite,"
it's number 10 on my list,
I'd like for you to watch it.
And of course, I hadn't
watched it in a long time.
It is so specifically strange.
You know?
Yeah.
And also innovative for its time too.
It's delightful.
So many people have tried
to do that quirky thing,
including Jared Hess himself has tried to
recreate the magic
that he sort of found
in "Napoleon Dynamite,"
and that's been difficult for him to do.
Well "Nacho Libre,"
I really love "Nacho Libre."
Yeah, I like that movie.
My whole family had watched that,
we may have watched it
twice over the years.
Jack Black is hilarious.
It's a really good movie.
So I would say
in Lily and Lando's opinion
it's a much better movie
than "Napoleon Dynamite."
Because at like 10 or 13
minutes in, they were like,
"Dad, is this the movie?"
They were like, "Is
something going to happen?"
Because it's just these strange characters
just being themselves.
And there's not a lot
that's really happening.
There's, I mean, they
couldn't keep watching it.
I had to turn it off, and we hadn't gotten
to any sort of question or conflict.
You're kidding.
Yeah, they weren't into it.
And they love "Nacho Libre."
My kids have watched, first of all,
my kids end up watching a
lot of movies without me,
like, especially Locke,
like, I'll be like,
"Hey, have you seen so
and so classic movies."
"Oh yeah."
He just watches a bunch
of stuff on his own,
so "Napoleon Dynamite,"
kids have watched that.
And they liked it.
I'm a fan of Jared Hess.
They weren't as into it as I was.
"Don Verdean, Biblical Archaeologist."
Well I think the thing
we like about Jared Hess
is that he,
if we were to make movies,
we've always thought,
especially because at that time,
like 2004 when that one came out,
we were thinking, we
were trying to figure out
what is this career gonna look like,
and where is this eventually going to go.
And I think we always assumed
that it would end at making movies.
And maybe it will Link,
maybe it will one day.
Right.
But we had this vision that, oh,
the way that he's kind of drawing on
the weird, quirky stuff from his life,
and his childhood, and the way
that he puts that on screen,
in very specific ways,
it's just how we imagined
that we would always make comedy.
It was a different type of comedy.
That's why it had to be
on my list, I felt like,
because it was so inspiring
for me, and for both of us,
because it was this
specific strain of comedy
that we had never experienced,
that every choice was a comedic choice.
And it came together
in a way that was like
it was so odd that it became
cool in spite of itself.
Even the music cues and like
the composition, everything,
was just delightfully strange,
and I think it gave us confidence that
those instincts, comedic
instincts that we had
that were kind of kindred
to his was something
that people could dig.
And it gave us more confidence
to explore our comedic voice.
So that's why I had to
make the list for me.
Okay, I'll pick up with
number nine in one second.
First, we do want to take a short break,
let you know that we've
got pop sockets, people.
At mythical.com, you can
go and pick up pop sockets.
We've got the mythical pop socket,
we've got the GMM pop socket.
I'm gonna put it up--
You can prop up your phone.
I'm gonna make it pop.
Now, we don't have it
on our phones right now
because we're going to sell these.
Check this out.
I mean.
It's very satisfying.
The thing about a pop socket
is that it's basically,
it's still the only acceptable
form of a fidget toy,
you know, it's kind of fart-ish.
And it feels good.
So again, kind of fart-ish.
Mythical.com.
That didn't, the words mythical--
Didn't come out of my mouth exactly right.
There's also a, we don't have
our hands on it right now,
there's a Feel Good
Mythical Morning pop socket.
So every time you look at
your phone and hold on to it,
it feels good, and you know what?
It feels good to pop in.
I did get that, actually, I just remember,
I got one of those in the mail I believe,
and it's just in a package.
Sorry, crew.
Sorry Mythical crew who
sent that to me on time,
I don't have it.
But it feels good and it looks good.
Go to mythical.com,
we got all types of stuff
including pop sockets.
We will just, let's get poppin'.
If you want to know what's
poppin', go to mythical.com.
Okay, back to the list.
We're to your number nine.
If you've lost track already.
Number nine.
What I consider to be the perfect movie.
Perfect movie and it's only number nine?
"The Godfather."
Okay, okay.
I thought that one of
these would make your list.
I mean people say "Godfather
Part II" is better.
Well, again, there's another trilogy,
as you might imagine, on my list,
there's probably at
least one on your list.
And I just pick the first one from,
I'm just picking the first
movie from the trilogy,
and "Godfather II" is incredible.
"Godfather III" is, everybody
sort of agrees is not as good,
but I love a gangster movie.
I absolutely, so obviously "The Godfather"
was Francis Ford Coppola,
and then Scorsese kind of came in
and has taken over the mantle of
the making the perfect gangster movie.
"Goodfellas," speaking of Scorsese, was,
almost took the spot on the list
because "Goodfellas" is
funnier than "The Godfather."
And I also think it's a
perfect movie, by the way.
And it's sort of the
modern gangster movie,
but a lot of the same characters,
it's just you have the
addition of Joe Pesci.
What they're playing the same characters?
They're not playing the same characters.
No, no, no, no, no, but I'm just saying.
It's the same actors.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
De Niro, you know,
so,
I love the epic sort of like sweeping,
multi-generational nature of
a really good gangster movie.
And again, that's what
they did in the Irishman
where they kind of took
him through his life
and I just sit there and I
just kind of just completely,
I become engrossed with this,
and I remember the first time
I watched "The Godfather,"
which I don't even remember how old I was,
but I was a teenager, and,
I very rarely have
gotten lost in something
and just been like,
because a lot of people are like,
man there's movies are so long,
like a Scorsese movie,
and "The Godfather,"
I don't know how long the
first one is, they're all long,
but like, it doesn't matter.
I could just take it, I could watch it,
I could watch like a
12 hour version of it,
because everything about it is perfect.
The writing, the acting, the
score, the cinematography.
I just don't think
there's any misses at all.
Although I was surprised to
learn that Marlon Brando,
two things about him,
he actually put cotton balls in his cheeks
when he did his audition for the role
because he wanted his face
to kind of like a bulldog,
more so than an already did.
And then for the movie they had a dentist
make like a prosthetic
that goes in his mouth
that pushes his cheeks out
and gives him that sort
of that way he talked.
Oh.
But he also, he's such a weird dude,
he didn't memorize any of
his lines for the movie,
he read them off cue cards.
Seriously?
And so, to learn that the lead actor in
one of the best movies of all time
wasn't really even acting
in the traditional sense.
Wow.
Was a little surprising, but.
So you're saying that a gangster,
well, okay, you don't have to,
but a gangster movie
didn't make your top 10?
No gangster movie.
And I, you know, I think a lot of people
may be thinking, Link,
you've got a reputation
of being the guy who
hasn't seen the movies.
And you know what, that's true.
Especially, like all of the
movies that everybody's seen
from the 80s, you know,
which is why we made that
ViewMaster thing for the Mythical Society
that put me in these
movies I've never seen
like "Ferris Bueller's Day Off."
But yeah, I've seen "The Godfather."
I've seen "The Godfather Part II,"
but there was a it was a stint in college
where I realized I needed to
go back and watch these movies
because in my house growing
up we just didn't watch,
we didn't rent that many movies,
or watch that many movies.
In your house, I just think that was like,
that was a big thing, right?
Yeah we watched a lot of movies.
And not only did you watch them together,
but you would also watch
the movies on your own.
But you'd rent those VHS of
"The Godfather," and watch that.
So in college, I watched those.
I watched, you know, "Space Odyssey 2001,"
you know I watched all
the things that, like--
Hold on, hold on, so 2001
didn't make your top 10?
No.
That was an honorable mention for me.
I was sure that that movie
would make your top 10.
I had that I had that kick where I took
an intro to film class my sophomore year,
and I really felt convicted to go back
and watch the greatest movies of all time.
And we would watch a lot of them together.
And there was a really cool, you know,
video store there were a lot
of you could rent for $1,
remember that?
Yeah.
So, I watched them all so closely together
that they didn't have a
lasting personal impact.
There are some from that time in my life,
but it says a lot more about me
than it does about the movie.
So no, no gangster movies in my list.
Okay, what is your number nine?
My number nine is
from 2014,
I was making my list and I realized
I didn't have a Marvel movie on my list.
And I feel like if I'm
going to see a movie now,
like without exception,
I go to the theater
to see a Marvel movie because
my entire family's into it,
it's a way that we connect.
We had a lot of really great memories
around watching movies,
we watched "Infinity War,"
and when it was over, we
had reservations for dinner
and Lily was in tears, and I was like,
emotionally ripped apart.
And we didn't even go, we
didn't even eat dinner.
We just went home, you know?
So I felt like I had,
Marvel had to be represented
on my list somewhere.
So at number nine, the only
Marvel movie on my list,
"Guardians of the Galaxy."
That's my favorite Marvel movie.
I mean, "Infinity War,"
the first "Avengers,"
like, there's a lot of
ones that are special.
But "Guardians" is just my favorite.
It's just, it's the funniest.
It was so surprising because I wasn't,
I'm not a comic book guy so I wasn't
really familiar with the characters.
So, my expectations were low
but then they were blown out of the water.
And it just continues to
deliver with every sequel.
I can't wait for the next one.
Yeah.
So, "Guardians of the
Galaxy" was on my original,
just like my long list.
And I kind of, so I guess
you could technically say
it's on my honorable mentions,
but it didn't really have it,
I knew it wasn't gonna
make it into the top 10.
Yeah.
But it is, for me, as a guy who
doesn't really like comic book movies,
it is easily the best franchise,
Marvel franchise for me.
And I think that's why it's on my list
for the reason it's almost on your list.
Plus all the reasons I love Marvel.
And one of the things that happens in
Marvel movies that is
frustrating to me is just,
I'm just not, the whole
action thing is not,
it's not super appealing to me, and like,
following a bunch of different,
like I like "The Avengers" and
they're incredibly well done,
but, like, just things
get too complicated.
It's not like it's difficult to follow
what's happening in "The Avengers,"
I'm not saying that, it's not
like "Memento," or something,
but it's--
There's emotional investment
in the entire universe.
It gets a little too complicated
and too complex for me
to like find out what I'm
supposed to attach to,
but for "Guardians of the Galaxy,"
I attach, I find that there's
an emotional connection,
the soundtrack, we play the soundtrack,
by far the most played movie soundtrack
in our house is "Guardians of the Galaxy."
It's going all the time.
Because, you know, what Chris Pratt
listens to in the movie, it's incredible.
And it's super funny.
So yeah, I definitely thought about it,
but I just couldn't give it a top 10 spot.
Alright, so, where you at?
Number eight.
I'm almost positive this
is not on your list.
Unless you're, you got something that
you've never told me.
"The Wizard of Oz."
Wow.
Really?
Okay.
Yeah, oh yeah.
Easily.
Okay.
And this for me is,
if you're a 42 year old person,
or somewhere along those lines,
you remember the "Wizard of Oz" coming on
every single year on television.
And for me, it was this
incredibly special,
like getting by myself, and
watching the "Wizard of Oz"
was this almost spiritual experience.
There's something absolutely
magical about that story.
I mean, it is recognized
as one of the best movies of all time,
on most people's list,
but that's not why I chose it.
That's why I remembered it,
but I was like oh yeah, "Wizard of Oz,"
like, I would, there's something about,
it's such an early time in
sort of cinematic history,
they were able to bring
this fantasy world to life
and when you watch it
you can kind of see like,
oh, I can kind of tell that
they're just in sort of a big room.
And that castle is painted on a wall.
But you can still tell
that it was flooring
for anyone the first time they saw it.
And even as a kid, I
can access that memory
of the first time I saw it,
and still being transported there.
Yeah well one of my favorite things that,
one of my favorite genres of literature,
and one of my favorite
genres of movie is the,
are fantasy movies where
there's a connection
to the real world, right?
So even though I don't like, you know,
"The Chronicles of
Narnia" is not on my list
because I didn't really like the movies.
I loved the books as a kid.
Yeah.
And the reason that the
"Chronicles of Narnia"
connected with me so much is because
it actually established a
connection between the real world,
in England, with this fantasy world.
As opposed to like "Game of Thrones,"
which is just a fantasy,
it's a world building fantasy
thing, which is awesome.
But the idea that you can actually
find a thin place somewhere in the world,
and actually move into the fantasy world
has been something that
has been fascinating
for me since I was a kid,
and I remember like walking in the woods
and like looking in trees,
and it's like is this it?
Is how you get to the fantasy place?
Even though I know that she was
technically just in a dream,
which is unfortunate
that that's how it ends,
spoiler alert, just the idea that this
girl from Kansas, the real world,
with her little dog goes into
this absolutely magical place
that was represented in this
incredible way, it's just,
it's definitely, I almost
put it higher on the list
because it looms so large in my childhood.
I gotta say now I do feel a little guilty
for not putting it on my list because
I remember that feeling of realizing
it was coming on television
again when I was a kid,
and being so excited.
It was gripping.
And it wasn't the type of thing that you
only watched half of it.
Once you were in it, you were in it.
You were like oh this is a
good part, this is a good part.
And for it to hold up that
well is absolutely amazing.
So iconic, yeah.
Okay, so my number eight
is a Wes Anderson movie.
Now, if I were to rank
my favorite filmmakers.
I think Wes Anderson may
be my favorite filmmaker,
he may take my number one spot.
So it kind of, this was
difficult for me that
I had to narrow, I, I ended up--
Can I guess, can I guess
which one you chose?
I had to put one on my list
and I didn't put one higher than this.
Yeah, you can guess.
Okay, well let me, before I guess,
let me just say that I
knew that a Wes Anderson
film would be on your list.
And a Wes Anderson film
almost made it on my list
because I don't like was was
interested as much as you do.
But he is, he's definitely in my
top five favorite filmmakers.
However, none of his movies
made the list for me.
And the movie that I would,
was almost on my list
at number 10, and almost knocked off
"The Good, The Bad and The Ugly,"
is one I'm sure is not on your list.
I bet you'd say "Fantastic Mr. Fox."
No, I would say "Rushmore."
"Rushmore" is great, and I was,
I was almost gonna put that
off for the kids last night
and then I realized it's rated R
and I didn't want Lando to watch it.
But--
So, I think you chose,
I think it chose--
I didn't choose "Rushmore,"
but I thought about it.
You either chose, I know you either chose
"The Royal Tenenbaums,"
or "The Life Aquatic,"
and I think you chose "The Life Aquatic."
You are right.
I saw, I wish I would have seen
"The Life Aquatic" in theaters,
I don't know why I didn't do that.
It came out in 2004,
"Rushmore" came out in 1998,
"Tenenbaums" came out,
closer to "The Life Aquatic."
I think "Tenenbaums" was the first movie
that I watched of Wes
Anderson, then I went back
and watch the previous ones.
It's a great movie, great acting.
And it was, it's so striking
the visual voice that he has,
and it really resonates with me.
I mean, it's not just
the meticulous control
that he applies to every single thing,
just seeing his process
when watching the movie,
I delight in that.
And I think that's something,
it just makes me feel, you know,
it's like a well oiled
machine or well cleaned room,
you know, it resonates with me
to see everything so perfectly symmetrical
and then the way that the comedy doesn't,
the first time you watch it you're like,
is that, I find that funny but
is that supposed to be funny?
And of course, once you
understand his voice,
you know it is.
Yeah, well that's why,
that's why he's one of
my favorite filmmakers,
I mean obviously the aesthetic stuff
that you're talking about, but for me,
it is the effortless comedy and the way,
and also his casting
is better than anybody
in terms of comedic casting.
Knowing who's going to
be funny without trying.
He's a master.
Gene Hackman was amazing at that.
He's a master at that.
The reason why I chose "Life Aquatic,"
even though some people will rank it
really low on their Wes Anderson list,
it was more whimsical, it didn't have,
in a lot of Wes Anderson movies
there's an underpinning of sadness,
and there's a lot of comedy
that comes from that.
I wouldn't call it dark comedy
but it's like sad comedy.
"The Life Aquatic" was kind
of a refrain from that,
it was more whimsical, you know, it was,
I mean, Bill Murray's character was tapped
into so much of what you get
with Bill Murray that like,
it was, he was very morose as a character,
but it wasn't, I never felt sorry for him,
I always felt, I just
thought it was hilarious.
And exploring that world, you know,
with the cutaways of
the ship and everything.
It was just, it was just more
fun throughout than "Tenenbaums"
So if I was gonna sit down and rewatch it,
I found myself going back to that one
more often for those reasons.
Yeah, I think the reason
it didn't make my list
is because I can, I
appreciate all those things
about Wes Anderson and I find
it's incredibly enjoyable
to watch his movies and
like everything about it
there's something you can keep finding
that you are enjoying.
But the one thing that
it doesn't do for me
is I don't get emotionally invested
in his characters in the same way.
However, the character I
got most invested in is,
you know, Schwartzman in
"Rushmore," interestingly.
And so I think that that's
why it was my favorite.
But yeah, it's just more like,
it's almost just like a filmmaking,
it's just an experience in
watching great filmmaking.
It's like going to an amusement park.
It's like going--
I never forget that I'm
watching a movie though.
I think that's the thing is
I never forget that I'm watching a movie.
It draws attention to itself.
That might sound strange, yeah.
Yeah.
Give me your number seven.
Okay.
My number seven.
Again, I wonder when we're going
to get some crossover,
because I don't think
this is, we're there yet.
Number seven for me is
"The Princess Bride."
Again, this is, this is a lot of people's,
one of people's, a lot of
people's favorite movie.
And I, again, it was one of those
that the first time I watched it,
I was just like, if
this is what movies are
I, this, I want to make movies, you know?
It's got that adventure quality but it's,
"The Princess Bride" for me
is just the peak of
sort of fantasy comedy.
Doesn't go all the way into
like a Monty Python place
that it's just completely unhinged.
Gets pretty close in a couple of places.
But again, there's just
something about the tone.
First of all, I'm huge Rob Reiner fan,
and he's done so many different things.
And then once I read,
which I've recommended this book before,
I'll recommend it again,
but the "As You Wish" book.
Yeah, the audiobook's great too.
Yeah, the audiobook's got a
bunch of the cast talking,
and it's got freaking
Andre the Giant in it.
But again, I just love
the way it came together.
I love, there's so many
epic moments in it,
and again it's just,
I just get lost in it.
I love "The Princess Bride."
I wish I would have seen it as a kid.
I don't know, I was deprived.
You know, I saw it,
I don't think I saw it
until after college.
And it's just a different thing.
Like I could see, I could see
the everything you're saying,
but I couldn't fully experience it because
it doesn't quite hold up
if you're not accessing
the first time you saw it
when you're younger, I think.
Yeah, well, and did you know that
the actor that they originally
wanted to play the giant
was not Andre the Giant.
Fezzik is the is the giant's name.
It was Arnold Schwarzenegger.
Oh wow.
Was the first choice,
and now first of all--
Just not cute enough.
Like Andre the Giant had this
cuteness that made it work.
Well, he also had this giant-ness.
Well yeah.
That Schwarzenegger actually doesn't have,
he's ripped, but he's not an actual giant.
Which is on my list.
But, because the whole, again,
you got to read the book, because,
well not the book that it's based on,
you know, "The Princess
Bride" by William Gold,
Goldman, Gold or Goldman,
anyway, I haven't read the book,
but people said it was
one of those things like,
oh, you can't adapt this book
and they had tried many different times.
Kind of like, did you, I didn't
even realize until recently,
they're, "Dune," another
book that they said
can never be adapted is being
made into a film right now.
I've heard that.
But it's still suspicious.
But anyways, it took 12 years,
12 years have passed between the time
that they were talking
about Arnold being Fezzik
to when it actually happened,
because it took so long
to get the film going,
and by that time Schwarzenegger
was just a massive star
and it would have been
incredibly odd and weird
for him to just play the giant,
and so they got a pro wrestler to do it,
who ended up being one
of my favorite parts
in any movie ever.
My number seven movie is the first movie
I ever remember seeing in the theater.
I don't know if it actually
was, but it probably was.
This was 1984.
So I was six, if I saw
it late in the theater,
maybe depending on when it
landed, I could have been seven.
My dad took me to see
"Indiana Jones and the Temple of Doom."
And in a recent episode,
well maybe months back,
I did talk about how we watched
all of the "Indiana Jones"
movies with the kids, so
I introduced them to them,
and they were enthralled as well.
Now, you could make the argument
that "Raiders of the Lost
Ark" is a better movie.
I would make that argument.
And "Raiders of the Lost Ark"
is on my honorable mentions.
But they both hold up, big time.
Oh they're great.
"Temple of Doom" is a lot darker.
"Temple of Doom" is not as funny,
but it holds a special place because
I don't know why my dad
took me to see this movie.
It was rated PG.
And then, because of the public reaction
to the darkness of "Gremlins,"
and "Temple of Doom,"
Spielberg lobbied that they
come up with a new rating,
which became PG-13, and
they change the rating
of "Temple of Doom" to PG-13.
One of the first movies
that got that rating.
So I just remember seeing the heart come
out of that guy's chest
and covering my eyes
in the theater and being
absolutely horrified.
And it was amazing.
Watching the movie back,
I couldn't believe how
endlessly entertaining it was.
One scene to the next you're just thrown
as he tumbles from one thing to the next
and it's absolutely endless, it seems.
Like you, you think it
can't get better than this,
the action can't get
more exciting than this,
and then it happens.
And it's, I mean, there are some problems,
you know, the cultural
portrayals of, you know,
and then like there's
the white savior thing,
I'm not saying it doesn't
have its problems,
and I'm not, I'm not defending those.
But, it holds a special place in my heart
because it scared the
crap out of me as a child,
and my kids loved it when they watched it.
It scared the crap out of
Lando, and he loved it,
a few weeks ago, so.
I definitely feel like, like I said,
"Raiders of the Lost Ark"
was was very close to making my top 10.
I kind of felt like I had to,
I wanted to put a Spielberg
movie in my top 10,
because that's how I ended up
kind of approaching this list
in a lot of ways, it was like,
I started realizing
filmmakers that I liked
their body of work the most,
and I was like, okay, I'm
gonna give you one film,
but I just, I couldn't do it
as much as I absolutely love
the Indiana Jones franchise,
and it does loom very
large in my childhood.
And you got like the dinner scene
where they're like eating the
bugs and the monkey brains.
There's so many iconic scenes.
That's GMM right there, man.
It's like, the thing that I
was horrified by as a child
is something that became a
cornerstone of my career path.
I've got a connection to this movie man.
Okay, my number six
is by far my most recent movie.
Okay.
I don't have my years in here,
I should have done that,
but this is just from a couple
years ago, few years ago.
"Get Out."
Yeah, I assumed, "Get Out"
was a was an honorable mention of mine.
Like I knew you had to hit horror,
and I knew even independent from that
you had to hit "Get Out," because,
it's so pivotal so culturally.
You might think, yeah, you would assume
there'd be more horror on my,
I like horror movies a lot, but,
and I enjoy watching them,
probably more than any movie
because I just enjoy the
idea of getting scared,
especially in a group of people.
And now Locke and I, every
single Saturday night
is horror movie night and the two of us
just go down into the garage
where we've got a television,
and no one else will get scared
because no one else can
hear what's happening.
But we've watched a bunch
of ridiculous horror movies.
But anyway.
Did you think about "Us,"
or is it clearly "Get Out" over "Us?"
"Get Out" is better than "Us," yeah.
I mean, there's so many things,
I love everything about both movies,
but "Get Out" was one
of the most enjoyable
movie going experiences I've ever had,
like the first time I
saw it in the theater.
I was feeling so many things all at once
when I was watching it.
The first thing I was feeling
was this is super scary,
and it's like getting me,
but this is super funny,
and like a really funny,
like a I'm laughing as much
as I am kind of cringing in fear.
And then the whole time I'm thinking,
Jordan Peele make this, you know,
it's just like Jordan Peele
of Key and Peele, comedy duo,
this guy has gone and
created this perfect movie,
there was this, there
was like a combination,
there was a fascination,
but also like an incredible
jealousy at the same time
to just think, dude,
this, this guy went off
and did this thing that, man,
I mean like, this is an
incredible accomplishment
for anyone, but this dude
that was just over here
doing sketch comedy had this
up his sleeve the whole time?
This is crazy.
But yeah, it's, I mean it's
one of my favorite movies.
Obviously it's number six on my list, but,
it just, I think it also sort
of represented the cultural
resurrection of horror,
bringing horror back into the mainstream
in a really big way.
A lot of people have seen
a lot more horror movies,
and horror movies are
grossing a lot more money
at the box office because of "Get Out"
and what it kind of did
for people getting like,
oh, I get it, it's kind of
like riding a roller coaster.
As opposed to just being
a bunch of horror scenes
going in and watching
people get slaughtered
in a movie theater.
My number six is my favorite, well,
I don't know, if you ask me
what my favorite comedy is,
it's weird because I have
comedies higher than this one,
but, I think of this as more of my like
if I'm going to go with like my,
the strictest version of comedy
that I'm going to apply to
something then make that list,
I think this is my number one.
My favorite just straight up comedy.
Released in 1998, "The Big Lebowski."
Wow.
You thought this would be higher.
Is your number six.
That's my number six.
Yep.
You thought it would be higher.
Well it's higher on my list
than it's on your list.
Okay.
But so you thought that I
liked the movie more than you.
I thought that it would,
I thought that it might be
your number one, honestly.
Yeah, at certain points in my life,
it would be, but, there's
other movies that just,
they resonate, they have more meaning,
they touch my life in a lot more areas.
This just kind of touches my funny bone
and my comedic sensibility.
I really regret not seeing
"The Big Lebowski" in theaters.
I think that was my introduction
to the Coen brothers.
This was, again, I was taking this
intro to film class
sophomore year in college,
I was able to rent it
because they were talking
about it in class.
And I was like, how have I
not heard about this movie?
It's absolutely hilarious.
It's also very profane,
and that's really edgy.
It was, I wrote, I had to write
a paper about mise-en-scènee.
Which is basically
arranging scenery and props.
And so I wrote a whole paper.
I'm horrible at writing papers.
But I had to watch the movie,
again and again and again
in order to piece together this paper.
So I got really acquainted
with it, but it never got old.
The performances from Jeff Bridges,
and John Goodman are just,
I feel like they're perfect.
And then the ways that they
interact and, you know,
it was the first thing that
I really started to notice,
because I don't watch a whole,
I don't watch a lot of movies
again and again and again.
That's just not, that's just not me.
But in such a short
span of time to do that
and still enjoy it,
and start to appreciate
the nuances of acting, I
think for the first time,
was another touch point for this movie.
But it was just, it was just so funny,
and still is so funny.
Yeah, I gotta say, it's my number two.
Wow!
Yeah.
When's the last time you watched it?
It's been years.
It's been years, and
I was talking to Locke
about how we should watch it together.
But I do, I know that one of the things
that people discover when they watch it,
and again, Coen Brothers
are some of my favorite
filmmakers of all time.
I wanted them to have a spot,
and this is my favorite
Coen Brothers movie.
The reason that it, well, lot of people
talk about the fact that nothing happens,
and I was actually reading
an interview with Joel Coen,
who says, "You know the
plot is sort of secondary
"to the other things that are
sort of going on in the piece.
"I think that if people
get a little confused,
"it's not necessarily
going to get in the way
"of them enjoying the movie."
So, in this interview
goes on to talk about
how like the plot is like
the fourth or fifth thing,
because there's an
aesthetic quality to it,
there's the characters, the
cut, the dialogue is incredible.
The situations.
I mean, like the baseball bat to the car,
with the homework under
the seat, you know it's.
Well and I think that it,
yeah I struggle between, like,
my list is a combination of
movies that do something to me
personally as a, just a movie watcher,
you know, as an audience member.
And then there are
movies that do something
for me as an audience
member, and aspiring artists.
And so, again, when I watch something
that Coen Brothers make,
I think a lot of it
has to do with the fact
that they're a duo, you know,
a duo that's known each other
forever as being brothers,
and so I think that when we look at them
we think a lot about our
careers and, you know,
we both read the book about
their sort of creative process, years ago.
And there's just something,
there's something
inspirational and aspirational
about them and their career,
and I feel like this is like the pinnacle
of where everything came
together in one movie for them.
And so, again, it's a kind of thing that,
and we always referenced this,
we talk, when we're developing
characters for ourselves
in some of the narrative
stuff that we've done,
we think about the dynamic,
we use those three characters
as points of reference
in a lot of the stuff that we create.
Like are you getting too Goodman here?
How Bridges are you,
or how Buscemi are you,
is your character, you know?
I think that there's just something
about that trio characters,
the dynamic's incredible.
Yeah, my number two,
and I thought it was going
to be your number one.
Your number six, wow, okay, I'm very,
I'm very interested to see
where your list goes from this, from here.
Okay, okay.
My number five is, again, I
think it's a perfect movie,
"Back to the Future."
Love everything about this movie.
A lot of people say
it's the perfect movie.
You know, it is not the one
where he goes to the future.
That's a bummer.
No.
Well, a lot of, it's interesting
because when I watched it,
I thought to myself, I was like man,
this movie has everything
that I want in a movie.
You know, it's got this sort of
reality bending nature
that if you're going
to make a movie, you might as
well do something mythical.
You know, I'll always say that,
something magical should happen.
So you got that sci-fi
element, it's incredibly funny.
And of course all the
choices that he makes,
are, I just think it's incredible
the way that it progresses.
But there's a lot of people who point out
the fact that Marty McFly
really doesn't grow or change,
which isn't really unusual thing,
which would normally happen in a movie,
is that it doesn't seem that
he really learns anything,
there's no like epiphany for him really.
But,
yeah, I just,
I watched this fairly recently,
like in the past five years,
and it was when it hit me,
I was like man I never, like
I loved this movie growing up,
but I just kind of, I lumped it together
with a lot of other
movies in that, you know,
you got all the Spielberg stuff and then
Zemeckis, of course, did this one.
But it's a very Spielberg-y type,
a lot of people just think
that Spielberg made it.
I did think he was a producer on it.
But Zemeckis, and then Robert
Gale wrote it together,
which, this is a really interesting thing,
I was reading about this,
in a 2015 interview, Zemeckis maintained,
so he and, Zemeckis
and Gale own the rights
to distribution of the film.
And the rights for all sequels.
And they say that both of them have agreed
that no reboots will be made
as long as they are alive.
So don't expect, it's one of those things.
and I love that because you
know they would screw it up.
It's one of those things that they would,
there's movie studios that
are chomping at the bit
to remake this movie knowing
that it would do really well
at the box office,
but you just can't
improve upon the original.
This is just one of those cases,
usually can't, but this
is just one of those cases
that there is something sacred about it.
Yeah.
It's the ultimate time travel movie.
The, and it's ultimate miss on my part.
You know, I think that that movie,
the fact that I didn't see that until
college in its completion,
maybe after college, again, is just,
I know that's mind blowing,
and it's just, you know--
You were deprived.
A childhood cut short or
something, I don't know.
Okay, so now we're at my number five.
Okay, so this is where I've
placed the Star Wars trilogy,
and I have made a choice of which one.
But yeah, here we are at number five,
with "The Empire Strikes Back."
I mean you can't argue, I
don't think you can argue
with that being the one
that you would choose
if you had to choose only one to watch
or to rank is your number one of,
you know, all nine of those.
But I did actually, I'm
just gonna be honest,
I did think a little bit
about "The Force Awakens,"
because for me personally,
it was, you know,
it was an opportunity to see
it, I don't remember seeing,
I think I can almost,
I don't remember seeing "Return
to the Jedi" in the theater.
So, it was, "The Force Awakens,"
that theater experience
after having waited so long
and then it being a shared
experience with my kids
and now Lily is, my whole
family, but most of all,
Lily is so into Star Wars,
to create that experience
and have that with her
is why "The Force Awakens,"
and it's just such a nostalgic movie,
because it's, you can
argue this is a remake
of "A New Hope," but I love that one,
but I'm still putting
"The Empire Strikes Back."
I wish I could have experienced that,
no, I am your father moment,
you know, for the first time,
actually experienced it,
that would have been amazing,
but, you know, everybody, by
the time we watched it we knew.
I don't remember not
knowing before I watched it.
Oh, oh yeah.
Especially in the theater.
I know I saw,
I don't think I saw any of the
first in the theater because,
I mean, that was '77, '80, and '83, right?
I think so.
So.
Right.
Yeah, I ended up watching
all those on VHS.
And I've never been, I love,
I am a fan of Star Wars,
and I like the most recent,
I really enjoy all the most recent ones.
But, yeah, it didn't even get,
they just didn't make an honorable mention
because another trilogy did, which I have,
I assume that another
trilogy also made your list,
which I enjoy more, which
we've talked about, but.
Listen, you don't have to apologize
for not putting Star Wars on your list,
you just have to endure the
wrath of all the Star Wars fans.
I think it's, the thing
I respect about Star Wars
is what it, is the mythology and sort of
the philosophy that goes into it
and how it translates into so relatable,
and you can use it in
so many illustrations.
But the actual just sitting
there and watching the movie,
especially the originals
it just doesn't get me,
it doesn't get me enough to
get into my favorite movies.
But you know what does?
Another movie that you're not gonna be
surprised it's on my list,
and I would bet anything
that is not on your list.
Number four, "Braveheart."
Oh, "Braveheart" was an
honorable mention for me.
I remember we were both
really into that in college.
I remember you'd be really
into the soundtrack,
like you own the CD.
Oh I had the soundtrack
and played it in my room.
Now, I don't know if it was
something about the fact that
I felt this like connection
with William Wallace,
because you know, I always
thought I was Scottish
even though I'm more Irish.
But there's something, it's
one of those movies where
I get so, again, nothing
about the movie appeals to me
from the in the
aspirational filmmaker side.
It's one of those movies
that I'm just completely
an audience member, and I get
completely lost in the story.
And every single thing about it, I just,
you feel like your heart
is just like beating
bigger and bigger throughout the movie,
and then the,
the ending of that movie.
Oh gosh.
The ending of that movie is just like,
it's like the first time I remember like
almost like weeping to the point of like
shoulder convulsions in a movie theater.
And it just something about the way
it emotionally connected with
me at that time in my life,
is, and I was talking to the
boys, we haven't watched it.
Yeah, it's very intense.
Yeah.
And, you know, it's also very funny.
There's funny moments
and you really care
about those characters.
And it's just sort of a,
it's a huge milestone,
kind of accomplishment,
in filmmaking, in just like an epic,
the scale of it, and the intensity.
I think it's one of the
first movies where there was,
they just made the decision to be like,
hey, when we show people
fighting like it's gonna be real,
like there's gonna be like swords
going into people.
Thousands of people died
because swords really went into people.
Well, interestingly, one of
the things I was looking at,
they talked about how they had to reshoot
a couple of the epic battle scenes because
a few of the guys had on
wristwatches and sunglasses.
And they would like see it,
and kind of seems like a myth
because they could just
go in rotoscope it out.
Those people deserve to be flogged.
I mean at that point,
in front of everybody.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You will be killed.
Pull their kilts up and
just give them a nice
fanny flogging, butt flogging.
Which brings me to my number four,
I, again, "Braveheart"
was an honorable mention,
but I had to put
"Apocalypto" at number four.
What an amazing Mel Gibson movie.
Just kidding.
You're joking.
Yeah, you remember that movie?
I was gonna say.
I remember Mel Gibson.
Yeah, it was good.
It was decent.
It was very violent.
I mean, "Braveheart" is very violent.
But anyway, that's not my number four.
My number four, I know I'm
gonna surprise you here.
I'm throwing another another
Coen Brothers movie up there,
and now you know what it is,
"O Brother Where Art Thou,"
went higher, two spots, than
"The Big Lebowski" for me.
Released in 2000.
I was a big Coen Brothers
fan by this point.
So I was determined I was gonna see
their next movie in theaters.
And I remember just feeling,
it was weird, I had this
connection to this movie
the first time I saw it.
Like, and I really think it had to do with
the type of comedy, it was
like that old time-y comedy,
and, the Southern humor,
and just the use of music.
I really felt like it was a
movie that we would have made.
I don't know, it was--
Yeah.
I actually, I feel this was
a complete miss on my part,
now that I'm thinking about it.
Like I don't know why that,
in all the lists that I
looked up to jog my memory,
"O Brother" didn't come up.
Well it didn't win a lot of awards.
George Clooney won a Golden
Globe for best comedy actor,
and I do think it won
best comedy or musical,
as a, and it won the
Grammy album of the year.
It won the freaking, the
soundtrack won album of the year
because it was--
The soundtrack was incredible.
Amazingly curated by T-Bone Burnett.
Every song.
Every song was great.
So yeah, the Southern comedy,
the way that the history,
and the way that music
was such a part, like,
at that point in my life
like, I mean, music's so important to me,
and there's been different
points when I thought
I could be a music historian,
not because I know a lot of stuff,
but because I could see myself investing
what it took to be that type of person.
And I felt like that's, it
was kind of like watching,
there was a documentary element to it.
It felt like I was watching
a Ken Burns documentary
on, you know, country music
in some aspects.
And so it resonated with
me on all those levels.
And then the comedy of
it, and the characters,
and it was just, and it was fun.
You know?
It wasn't too heavy.
So it--
Yeah like I said, I love it and,
I don't know where I would put it,
but it didn't even come into my mind
in putting my list together
and now I'm starting to think,
hmm, I think it would have made my top 10
had I realized that,
for all of the reasons
that you just explained.
I demand a written apology
to Ethan and Joel Coen.
Well I put "The Big
Lebowski" at number two, so.
Yeah, that's true.
Okay, number three.
We're gonna have some, we're gonna have
some crossover in the top
three, we have to, I think.
My number three, I had to pick
one, I picked the first one,
"The Fellowship of the Ring,"
of "Lord of the Rings."
Having recently watched the trilogy again,
I thought that the "Return
of the King" was my favorite
but in rewatching it, they're
actually in reverse order now.
Number one is the best number,
two is the second best,
and number three is the third best.
But they're all incredible.
In rewatching it, I was, as
we discussed a few weeks ago,
just fully engrossed.
We're still going through
all of the DVD extras
which there's like
reams of that, and like,
the kids are into that, like I said.
In this particular rewatching,
"The Two Towers" was my favorite.
But what number was it for you?
It is my number two.
Okay, yours is number two.
So my number three.
So it's not my number three or number one.
Again, it's one of those things,
like we said a couple weeks ago,
you realize, I mean, first
of all, we read the books,
and we were both big fans of the books.
It's, you know, it's a
completely different thing
than "The Chronicles of Narnia."
"The Chronicles of Narnia"
were probably my all time favorite series
because of when I was reading,
at the age I was reading it,
but it's for kids.
Yeah.
It's a kids book.
Whereas you pretty much have
to be a teenager, or older,
to really, I think, get into
"The Lord of the Rings."
I didn't read the books
until the movies started coming out,
but I read each book
before the movie came out.
Only time I've ever done that.
Well "Game of Thrones"
I read all of the books
before I watched any of that.
And it only helped, especially--
Yeah.
Especially because they were so reverent
of the books when they made the movies.
And now, as I've already
recommended the extended versions.
Yeah, it's the perfect,
from a literary standpoint,
it is the perfect fantasy series.
It's been emulated.
But it's never been
superseded, I don't think.
And then, like you said,
the fidelity that the movie,
the way that they translated
the books into the films.
The level of detail,
the level of attention,
it's just something that I don't think
it had never happened before
and it hasn't happened since.
No one's ever adapted
something with that much care.
The way that you can watch
a superhero movie and
I understand how someone might
feel like, you know what,
it's just a little ridiculous,
it's a bit too much for me,
I just can't get into it.
I think you could say that
about "Lord of the Rings"
if it wasn't "Lord of the
Rings" but the fact that it was,
it is what it is, it has such a deep
well of backstory and history,
and a language and everything,
it's easy to just immerse
yourself in that world and to,
because you can't be, it's
really hard to be critical of it
because it's done so well.
Whereas if it's not you
can just roll your eyes,
in that genre.
That's what happened with Narnia,
you know?
Right.
Okay, so my number three.
I've been on record,
you shouldn't be surprised,
I've been on record saying
this is the best movie of all time.
And it sounds like I'm
saying it as a joke.
I can't believe it made number three.
My number three movie of
all time, released in 2003,
with no apologies from me is "Elf."
"Elf" is one of, is my third
favorite movie of all time.
You know, I didn't see it in the theater.
It's sad that so many of my movies
on my list I didn't see in the theater,
but we watched it, of course
we watch it every year Christmas.
And every year at Christmas I'm like,
I forget how good this movie is.
One of these years I'm going to expect it
to be as good as it actually is.
Every scene, I mean, it taps
into the nostalgia of the,
of those old stop motion movie,
Christmas movies that we'd watch,
"Rudolph the Red Nosed Reindeer"
and "Frosty the Snowman."
"Frosty the Snowman."
It pays perfect homage to those.
It's Will Ferrell in this
like super sweet mode,
that's really, winsome.
Every scene, it's like oh yeah,
this one's, this is a really good scene,
and this is a really good scene, and it's,
the scenes build the movie.
In some way, it's kind
of like, I know that,
like a weird and maybe
obvious thing to say,
but what I'm trying to get at is
it's not just
what, everything that
happens you feel like
this is my favorite part of the movie.
And then the next thing that happens,
oh no this is my favorite
part of the movie.
And you go through,
there's only a few places where
that's not really the case.
Like every scene has something
that in that moment that you're watching
it makes you think it's the best.
It's like listening to The Hall and Oat's
greatest hits album, when you're like,
oh, this is their best song,
and then the next one comes on.
That's my experience in watching "Elf."
And then there's, there's all
the memories of watching it
with my family every year and
everybody's still loving it,
nobody rolling their eyes.
Okay, it's a great movie.
And when we do top 10 favorite
Christmas movies of all time,
it'll be my number one.
Hey, you don't have to say anything,
you don't have to say anything.
No, no I mean, I think it's funny.
It's a funny movie but it's funnier that
it's your number three
favorite movie of all time.
Jon Favreau wanted to,
he was exploring making a sequel,
but Will Ferrell didn't seem too into it.
It's come up a few times over the decades,
but it ain't gonna happen.
I don't think it should happen.
I don't want it to happen.
Okay, well I've already
told you my number two.
I've already told you my number two.
Which is "Lord of the Rings."
Oh, so we're going to number one.
So now we are both--
Where we obviously agree.
Yeah, we know what our
number one is, right?
This is the thing that there was no,
there was no question.
I knew what I was going
to put in my number one,
and that wasn't the difficult part,
the difficult part was
filling the list out.
But we'll say it on the count of three,
and we'll say it at different times
because of the delay
between our two video chats
but three, two, one.
"Pulp Fiction."
There it is.
Released in 1994.
Quentin Tarantino's follow
up to a "Reservoir Dogs."
When I watched this movie, I went to,
it's interesting, we didn't
watch this movie together.
It was really gaining momentum.
It had been out for a while.
And I went to the Rialto theater,
which is like in Raleigh
at like Five Points where--
That's where, I saw it at the
Rialto for the first time,
but did I see you because
you took me back to it?
I think so.
I know I didn't watch it
the first time with you.
I think I watched it with Missy,
my girlfriend at the time.
Because that was 19,
it might have been '95
by the time we saw it, because
it took a while to get going
and we were, I was,
we were definitely dating at the time.
But the funny thing is I don't
remember who I saw it with.
I remember the theater, I
remember the theater had a stage.
And it had these two big speakers
just exposed and sitting out there
below the screen, and it,
it was a small theater,
and you would just walk down the sides
and then go into the middle,
really old, rickety squeaky seats.
And right, it just felt,
it was the first time I'd
seen a movie at the Rialto,
or any, like, art house theater.
And I felt so out of place.
Yet, so cool being there.
You know, I was, being in high school
and it was just like, there
were these hipster college kids
and like these old guys wearing sweater,
you know cardigans, like Professor types,
and they were drinking
beer in their seats, and,
it was, and then the movie started,
and it started in in such a different way
than any movie I'd seen.
It had this opening title credit sequence,
and I'm like, what is this?
Yeah well he did, I
remember the feeling of,
after I watched that movie,
and this has happened a few times,
where you just got to
sit there for a while.
You can't get up.
Well it was confusing because it,
it was, you know, it
was circular narrative,
it was presented out of order,
and so like--
Well, he was just,
he was doing things that we
had never been exposed to.
First of all, we hadn't really
seen anything that violent.
You know?
In your face, like, I
mean the type of violence.
Gratuitous.
Gratuitous, violence to
the point, and again,
this is controversial,
Tarantino's controversial,
there's gonna be people who are mad at us
because we put this as the number one.
But listen, this isn't,
we're not trying to please
anybody with this list,
we're just telling you what
our favorite movies are.
And I know Tarantino is
a controversial figure.
But the impact that movie had on me,
and the fact that he
made extreme violence,
funny, and I don't know,
I know that that's that's problematic,
and I find that problematic,
and I wouldn't personally create it.
But even, the scene where shoot Marvin,
and it's actually the most horrific
thing that you can imagine, but yet,
incredibly funny at the same time.
Tarantino had this way
of tapping into this
sort of dark part of every person
who wants to laugh at violence
because they don't know how to compute it.
Well, the thing that was funny was the,
it was in those characters worlds
it was just another day at the office.
And so it was the most honest way
for those characters to
react to that accident.
And it was funny,
like I mean, the dialogue.
The dialogue is, it's unlike anything,
we had never experienced that like,
the royale with cheese
conversation that they have
in the car in the first half of the movie,
I remember us talking about
that and thinking like,
no one's ever, no one's ever,
we had never been exposed to anybody
who would have this completely
tertiary conversation.
We might have weird conversations.
For extended.
It felt like there was a
resonance in the fact that
time was dedicated to two characters
having this strange conversation.
That's not moving anything along.
And it really, except that it
because they were walking
up and they were armed,
you know, depending on what, you know,
they were going to do something,
all this tension was built, because--
There's tension.
What's happening?
I find this extremely
funny, but it's also,
I'm really tightening
up inside, and it was,
and I was aware of the filmmaking process
more so than I ever had been,
maybe completely for
the first time that like
a director's voice could move me.
And it, so that was extremely inspiring
to make a connection between the decisions
that a director had made,
and the experience that I was having.
Yeah, and another part of that,
that I think you'll agree with,
is when we made movies, you know, like,
when we made "Gutless
Wonders" or whatever,
and some of the stuff
that we will start filming
and writing at the same time growing up,
we didn't think about film
scores as scoring, right?
We didn't think about people making music
that is intended to accompany.
In our minds, the way
that we thought about
film scores was soundtracks,
we thought about songs that
were cool that had a vibe
that you put into a
certain part of the movie
and that's what Tarantino
did in that movie.
That soundtrack introduced
me to genres of music,
I mean that soundtrack
introduced me to Al Greene.
Yeah.
And from then on, it's like, oh,
I'm an now Al Greene fan, you know?
And every single song
was so carefully chosen.
And I think that that resonated with us
because the way that we think about music
and the way we think about
music being matched to
something on screen,
and he was, he continues
to be a master at that,
but that was something we,
even though it had been done,
it hadn't been done in
nearly the same way.
And the fact that, I mean.
Basically if you, if you're
reading about cinema,
and you're reading about this movie,
you're gonna read about "Pulp Fiction"
being a cultural watershed,
whether you like it or not.
So it I think it was so
special to both of us
and became our number one
because we experienced,
personally, firsthand, in that moment,
the cultural watershed, not just for film,
but it impacted so much more,
and to be at the age where that
watershed could happen through,
it can run through our body,
just coursing through our
veins as we watched this thing,
I didn't know that I was
the one that brought you
to watch the movie again,
but I can definitely
believe that to be the case,
because I, having experienced it,
I knew that you had to experience it.
And I'm glad that we both went back there,
I just don't think it was
running anywhere else anyway,
or maybe it was just the
coolest place to see it.
Because it was still,
it was you know they had 250, 265 F words.
Which set the record by
a long-shot for years.
I'm sure Lebowski beat
that four years later.
Well, but the highest, Tarantino's
highest number of F words is 269.
Do you know what that was?
"Inglorious Bastards?"
No, "Reservoir Dog."
So he actually used to
use the F word more.
Oh.
Than he does now, but,
yeah I think it was, it was
one of those things that.
Interestingly, even though, you know,
me and you come from a
conservative Christian background,
and we were definitely like
very serious Christians at the time,
we never really, we didn't have a,
there's a big aversion
to cursing, and violence,
and that kind of thing, and, you know,
the whole like tipper gore,
put parental advisory,
there's a big aversion to
a lot of that at that time,
especially in the 90s.
But we never were really apart of that,
we all we always kind of gravitated
towards those things that
seemed a little bit subversive,
maybe because our personal lives were not,
there's nothing subversive about
any of the things that
we were actually doing.
So maybe it was somewhat of
an outlet for us, or whatever.
But I think that that is
one of the reasons that
it was controversial at the time.
It's like you can't do that,
you can't say, why would you use
the F word 265 times in a movie?
And you know what, it is excessive.
But it's almost like that's why he did it
because it was excessive.
That's why the, there are scenes in there,
that are like, why did you
have to put that in there?
And it's like, exactly.
Because he was like, I'm
just gonna, I'm gonna do this
almost as a way to sort of shock you into
welcoming my style of filmmaking.
For better or worse.
Well there's more controversial
choices than that,
which we won't, I don't
want to get into but.
Oh yeah.
Yeah, and I think it
was a time and a place,
and being a part of that
experience puts it at number one.
And you know what the what,
I hate to go back to "Elf,"
I got to go back to "Elf," if I may,
because I left out one thing that I found.
You know the burp, where
he like drinks the whole
two liter coke and then he like
does the longest burp ever,
and he's like, "Did you hear that?"
So funny, right?
Great movie.
Yeah.
It was a real burp, and it
was from a voiceover artist
named Maurice Lamarche who was the voice
for one of my favorite animated characters
who made my TV movie
list, in that episode,
He was the voice of the Brain
in "Pinky and the Brain" in Animaniacs.
Oh wow.
He did the burp for "Elf."
Well you know, one
additional piece of trivia
about "Elf" is there was one word
that was also used 265
times in that movie,
it was the "Elf" word.
Oh gosh.
Okay, so there you have it.
That's each of our top 10s.
I couldn't resist, couldn't resist.
Not as much overlap as I
thought might could happen.
Wait hold on, so you had, obviously
we had the same number one,
and then we both had "The Big Lebowski,"
both had "Fellowship of the Ring."
Yeah.
And was that it?
I think that's it.
My honorable mentions were "Toy Story II,"
"Her," "The Peanut Butter Falcon,"
"Forrest Gump," and the other
ones that I already mentioned.
Yeah, let me quickly run through mine.
Those are good ones
that you just mentioned.
"Groundhog Day," "Rushmore,"
"Dead Poet's Society,"
"The Usual Suspects,"
"The Matrix," "Fargo,"
"One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest,"
"Apocalypse Now."
Oh.
"Forrest Gump," "Raiders of the Lost Ark,"
"2001: A Space Odyssey,"
"The Shawshank Redemption."
Oo, yeah.
"Cabin in the Woods."
"Cabin in the Woods," which
I'm going to be talking about
on another YouTube channel.
"Toy Story," and then "Napoleon Dynamite."
You're going on who's channel?
I'm going on Dead Meat James.
Okay.
I don't know when that's coming out
but you talked about your
favorite horror movie,
and "Get Out" was too obvious of a choice
so I'm talking about "Cabin in the Woods."
Yeah that's a good one.
All right, there you have
it, our honorable mentions
as well as our top 10s.
I'm not going to give another rec,
because this whole episode is a rec.
Pick some of those to
watch with your loved ones,
and maybe we jogged
your memory to go back.
Hashtag Ear Biscuits, let us know.
Just don't watch "Pulp
Fiction" with your family.
Yeah.
Unless your family is all adults.
Right.
Even then it'll get awkward.
Hashtag Ear Biscuits, let us know,
you can put your top 10.
Just tweet it at us,
we'd love to see that.
Yeah, tweet your top 10,
well tell you if you're right or wrong.
And we'll speak to you next week.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits
click on the playlist to the left.
and don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.